bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60,18 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce mardi 9 mars
en ce début du mois le point sur la
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 dans
les yvelines le week-end dernier la
campagne s'est accélérée dans le
département avec des centres qui sont
restés ouverts
quatre nouveaux d'ailleurs sont mises en
place cette semaine sur le territoire
invité mario jean ali directrice de la
délégation départementale des yvelines
de la rsi de france il a été élu en
novembre dernier mais le conseil
municipal des jeunes de
voisins-le-bretonneux s'est réuni pour
la première fois samedi 6 mars
25 enfants le composent afin de proposer
des idées pour l'amélioration de leur
commune enfin depuis 2008 le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines organise des ateliers lire et
choisir le principe les collégiens
sélectionne un livre coup de coeur et
rencontre son écrivain un reportage au
collège paul eluard à guyancourt très
fortes tensions dans les hôpitaux liées
à la crise sanitaire du coc vide 19 en
ile-de-france mais un confinement n'est
pas d'actualité pour la région annoncent
ce matin du directeur général de la
santé jérôme salomon sur les ondes de
nos confrères d'rtl les yvelines et le
reste de la région font partie des 23
territoire source surveillance renforcée
le confinement affirmé jérôme salomon
serait un dernier recours dans le cas où
l'hôpital ne pourrait pas tenir
souvenez vous le 31 décembre dernier le
tout premier vaccin contre le coc vie de
19 et est administré dans un ehpad de
sartrouville depuis la campagne de
vaccination s'est accélérée dans les
yvelines on en parle dans un instant
mais comment se portent les premiers
vaccinés justement deux mois après elle
nous sommes retournés sur place le
reportage de célia garçons go rappelez
vous il était l'un des premiers
habitants des yvelines à se faire
vacciner
après deux mois jean berthier 90 ans est
en forme
moi j'aimerais revenir dès que les
résidents des ehpad était prioritaire
dès l'arrivée des vaccins en france dans
cette maison de repos à sartrouville 24
résidents sur 34 ont pu se faire
vacciner
madeleine brunet 94 ans a elle aussi
fait ses deux injections du vaccin
eiser par s'est bien passée c'était bien
organisé
la pole problème on nous a surveillé
pendant quelques temps après la
vaccination
parfois je ce que je souhaiterais que
tout le monde puisse avoir c'est blake 6
nations y a que comme ça qu'on s'en
sortir
la situation dans les ehpad a évolué
avec les vaccinations
dorénavant les visites ne sont plus
chronométrés et elles peuvent se faire
en chambre ça fait du bien
notre priorité c'est le bien-être des
résidents donc le b n est pas que
physique
le bien-être moral est important et
franchement ça se passait très bien
les résidents peuvent recevoir les
membres de la famille pour le déjeuner
les résidents peuvent sortir de
l'établissement également avec bien sûr
les mesures barrières à respecter le gel
hydroalcoolique le port du masque
mais oui les choses ont un peu changé
dans l'établissement un nouveau souffle
pour les résidents qui avait perdu le
moral ça m'a donné 10 en crise voyez je
suis sorte l'herbe pour l'impression
d'être incarcéré dans une prison dans
cet établissement des familles ou des
résidents ont d'abord refusé la
vaccination
ils ont finalement changé d'avis 32
résidents sur 34 devrait donc être
vaccinés dans cet état tu es pour
approfondir ce sujet de la vaccination
avec nous en visioconférence maria chin
à libon soir directrice de la délégation
yvelines de la rs ile de france l agence
régionale de santé avant de faire le
point avec vous sur la vaccination
cette vaccination s'accélère annonces du
premier ministre la semaine dernière
même pendant le week-end et des doses
ont été injectés 51000 au niveau
francilien les 6 et 7 mars le site du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a aussi participé à cette
opération exceptionnelle sur place 1700
personnes ont étés primo vacciner elles
sont issues des centre communal d'action
sociale et des listes d'attentes des
médecins des douze communes de
l'agglomération
environ 6000 personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées sur le territoire saint
quentinois
l'objectif est de monter en puissance et
d'atteindre à terme les 10000
vaccination par semaine
écoutez ses interviews on s'est
redressée ray mairie et puis
inscrits puis voilà il nous agents pour
telle vers nos petits-enfants c'est
surtout c'est la confiance qui est
donnée par l'état l'a encore une fois au
centre de vaccination de saint quentin
en yvelines parce que nous sommes en
capacité de faire fonctionner à plein
durant le week end
ce centre de vaccination dont doivent
observer les annonces du premier
ministre étaient cinquante mille doses
de vaccin pendant le week-end pour
l'ensemble du territoire français nous
en avons 1500 ça veut dire que nous
avons aussi récupéré un certain nombre
de doses qui étaient destinés à d'autres
centres de vaccination qui n'ont pas eu
les moyens en tout cas de s'engager à la
faire fonctionner à plein durant le
week-end donc 1712 pour le vaccinodromes
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines marion de
chine alliée au niveau des yvelines au
niveau global c'est 5500 injection qui
ont été réalisés ce week end
oui exactement faire 1555 très
précisément injection ce week-end on a
ouvert nos neuf centres de
vaccination qui ont accepté de jouer le
jeu et de pouvoir en fait réalisé sur le
week end
l'entièreté de ce qu'ils réalisent
habituellement sur la semaine est ce que
cette vaccination le week-end va se
poursuivre justement sur sur les
prochains c'était uniquement prévu pour
le week-end dernier
donc là on était plutôt sur une
opération coup de poing pour le week-end
dernier en revanche que les la
vaccination va monter en charge
puisqu'on a des doses qui vont arriver
beaucoup plus massivement au cours du
mois de mars est nettement plus à partir
d'avril et ça va suivre sur les mois mai
juin juillet et cetera donc du coup
c'était une préchauffe pour pour la
montée en charge de 90 de nos centres et
du coup pour les futurs centres
également que nous allons ouvrir
justement avec cette montée en charge
aujourd'hui à combien de personnes en
est-on vacciner dans les yvelines dans
les yvelines aujourd'hui on a dépassé 95
mille personnes vaccinées tout cumulé
plus de 65000 personnes en première
injection et plus de 29 mille personnes
en deuxième injection et les objectifs
en mode mars quels sont ils
pour le mois de mars on a une dotation
supplémentaire de 65 mille doses pour la
région ile de france sur les modes de 2
mars et donc ses 51 mille doses
complémentaire et ce matin on a appris
qu'on avait trente mille doses encore de
plus ce qui allait arriver sur la région
ile-de-france donc tout ça va être
répartie sur les départements et puis
ensuite nous réalisons la répartition
entre les centres par rapport à ce que
les centres sont en capacité d'absorber
on travaille avec eux pour savoir
comment ils peuvent armés leur
dispositif pour pouvoir absorber le
maximum de doses alors dans les yvelines
si on met de côté le centre de
vaccination de l'hôpital mignot à
versailles qui est destiné lui
uniquement aux professionnels de santé
neuf sites et est ouvert depuis janvier
dans le département c'est le cas vous
voyez sur cette carte à vélo vélodrome
de montigny le bretonneux à rambouillet
mantes la jolie ou encore saint germain
en laye et ça a été annoncé à ses neuf
centres sont venus s'ajouter quatre
nouveaux sites dont l'ouverture était
prévue cette semaine au menu halle saint
cyr l'école crêpière et sartrouville
portant le nombre total de centre a13
dans les yvelines est ce que ces sites
ont bien pu ouvrir cette semaine où
vont-ils être très prochainement
ils sont en train d'ouvrir ce matin on
était haut mais nul avec monsieur le
préfet cet après midi c'est sartrouville
donc ils sont en train d'ouvrir cette
semaine mais ils sont déjà organisés
pour pouvoir absorber leurs leurs
dotations et que qu'on a fixés avec eux
et c'était important de pouvoir rouvrir
ses cendres pour continuer à mailler le
territoire tel qu'on l'a toujours fait
depuis le 18 janvier donc c'est vrai
qu'on les avait pas en ouvert de prime
abord parce qu on avait une difficulté
de de réception de ces doses avec les
annonces de pfizer mais maintenant qu'on
y voit un peu plus clair c'était
important qu'on puisse continuer à
maillé ce territoire est toujours au
plus près de la population
de combien de 12 hebdomadaires seront
dotés ces nouveaux centres
alors ça ça dépend des semprun ça dépend
de leur capacité à pouvoir armer les
gros centres vont démarrer avec 600 dose
hebdomadaire et les plus petits centres
avec 452 hebdomadaires dont crêpière et
les mais nulle part tirant sur la base
de quatre cent cinquante deux ans
primo-injection parce qu'ensuite on
ajoutera les secondes injections et donc
sartrouville et puis
j'ai perdu notre sartrouville sentir
d'école le quatrième trouver les
saint-cyr-l'ecole sens sur la base de
six cents 600 injection 600 primo
vaccination est en plus de ses centres
il ya un maxi bus pour démarrer en plus
de ses centres il ya un maxi bus
également qui circulent sur le
territoire qui va sillonner les communes
rurales des yvelines
les communes qui ne sont pas couvertes
par ces centres de vaccination s'est
adressé aux personnes de plus de 75 ans
on peut dire vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un maillage plus efficace sur le
territoire c'est ça un dispositif
supplémentaire pour assurer ce maillage
justement exactement en fait on a lancé
des opérations d'aller vers ce qu'on
appelle à aller vers les populations qui
sont le moins mobiles pour plusieurs
raisons des régions sociétal des raisons
personnelles des raisons de santé
et donc on a mis différentes actions en
place levac six bus en lien avec le
conseil départemental qui va aller
prioritairement sur les communes des
intercoms il n'y avait pas de centres de
vaccination donc là cette semaine nous
sommes à coeur d'yveline la semaine
dernière on était sûr galimov frais la
semaine prochaine on sera sûr l'interco
des portes d'île de france
on va continuer comme ça en allant
partout en fait les communes sont le
plus éloignés des centres de vaccination
mais on a aussi des opérations notamment
avec une équipe mobile dédié auprès des
personnes âgées en foyer de travailleurs
migrants en résidence sociale
et puis également en lien avec le
conseil départemental sur les résidences
autonomie ou là on a des équipes mobiles
du conseil départemental qui se déplace
vers les résidences autonome et toutes
ces opérations n'émarge pas sur les
dotations des centres de vaccination
sont des autres des dotations
spécifiques qui sont données pour ses
opérations d'aller vers dernières
questions sur la vaccination dès le 15
mars le gouvernement a annoncé que les
formations pourrait également vaccinés
ce qui suscite visite
la colère des médecins libéraux qui
redoutent de devoir annuler des
rendez-vous de vaccination car les
commandes de dos seront tous verte cette
semaine aux seuls officie de ma question
c'est ce que les pharmaciens dans les
yvelines vont pouvoir vacciner dès la
semaine prochaine est acquis va
s'adresser justement cette vaccination
alors en fait effectivement la
difficulté qu'on a c'est juste sur la
semaine prochaine où il ya une
problématique de livraison mais en fait
in fine il y aura des doses en nombre
pour que et les médecins et les
pharmaciens puissent vacciner chacun
pour ce qui les concerne
et donc là il s'agit d'une vaccination
en astrazeneca donc on est toujours sur
les publics 50 75 ans et est donc les
pharmaciens seront autorisés
effectivement à vacciner la semaine dès
la semaine prochaine enfin il l'était
déjà pour venir en appui des centres de
vaccination ce week end avec une prise
de rendez-vous à faire sur internet au
préalable par sas et chaque pharmacie
qui va s'organiser pour le moment je il
va falloir voir on n'a pas forcément de
prise de rendez vous sur d'octo libre
avec les pharmacies alors un dernier
point avec vous on met de côté la
vaccination pour faire le point
justement sur l'épidémie de kobe de 19
dans les yvelines et nous relayons
chaque lundi dans le journal les
derniers chiffres de l'épidémie sur une
semaine dans le département la situation
est toujours tendue et se crispe eux
mêmes au niveau français mais avec des
lits de réanimation occupé à plus de 80%
on a appris par ailleurs hier que les
établissements de santé franciliens
devaient des programmes et 40% de leurs
activités médicales et chirurgicales
pour libérer des places en réanimation
est-ce que la situation à l'instar de
l'île de france et ce qu'elle reste
inquiétante dans les yvelines
notamment à cause des variants on a
appris la semaine dernière c'est le
premier ministre qui qui nous l'a appris
que sur les nouveaux cas de
contamination plus de 60 % provenaient
des variants dans les yvelines le
s'agissant des mario on tourne
maintenant sur les pcr positive à plus
de 70%
mais ça c'est la photographier aussi
régionales on
70% des pcr positifs qui sont des pcr
avec des variants donc effectivement la
circulation virale est nettement plus
importante concernant la pression sur
l'hôpital elle est bien présente et vous
le savez on a une régulation d'élite
soins critiques qui est régionale qui
n'est pas uniquement départementale donc
nous aujourd'hui le département des
yvelines en termes d'indicateurs c'est
le département c'est pas c'est pas là la
situation n'est pas la plus
problématique puisque notre taux
d'incidence est le plus bas de la région
mais pour autant on subit aussi cette
pression auprès de notre hôpital de tous
les deux tous les malades qui entre à la
fois sur des lits de médecine est à la
fois en soins critiques merci mario
cinelli pour toutes ces précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes là la
directrice de la délégation
départementale de la rs ile-de-france l'
agence régionale de santé et dans cette
actualité du coc vie de 19 la situation
dans la commune de chambourcy inquiétait
dans le département un cluster avec des
cas de variance sud africains avaient
été révélées les écoles de la commune
avait dû rester fermée une semaine
supplémentaire après les vacances
elles ont bien rouvert dès ce lundi avec
une opération après une opération de
dépistage massives dans la ville 1129
personnes testées résultat 13 cas
positifs dont 7 aux variants parmi
lesquels 12 adultes et un enfant de 1 an
en parallèle les tests salivaires ont
également débuté dans les écoles de la
région ce sont les écoles d'orgeval qui
ont été les premières à les effectuer
dans le département et sur les 768
enfants testés jeudi 4 et vendredi 5
mars et 12 était positive provoquant la
fermeture de quatre classes dans la
commune cette campagne de dépistage
salivaire a été lancée à grande échelle
en ile de france et va se poursuivre
notamment dans les yvelines sous
l'organisation de l'éducation nationale
au chapitre politique les élections
régionales je vous le rappelle qui
devrait se tenir les 13 et 20 juin
prochains pour son premier déplacement
de campagne dans les yvelines
elles auront saint-martin tête de liste
la république en marche en ile de france
et est à beaune elle c'était à la ferme
des clos pour rencontrer des
agriculteurs astrid bergère c'est à la
ferme des clos à bonnel dans lé sud
yvelines
que le candidat a l'air même aux
élections régionales en île de france
laurent san martin a fait son premier
déplacement de campagne vendredi 5 mars
normalement dans un monde normal on
aurait dû se rendre avec grand plaisir
comme chaque année au salon de
l'agriculture
voilà cette année nous avons fait le
choix évidemment d'aller malgré tout à
la rencontre de ces professionnels de
ces agriculteurs et c'est pas plus mal
finalement un mal pour un bien
nous ne sommes pas au salon porte de
versailles mais nous sommes directement
dans les exploitations
c'est mieux on comprend mieux la réalité
du terrain c'est je crois la façon la
plus sincère d'échangé dans cette ferme
plusieurs producteurs se sont rassemblés
certains même issu de reconversion
professionnelle apiculteurs houblonnière
maraîchers ici on cohabite s'est
accompagnée d'aurore berger députés de
ce territoire que le candidat est venu
je crois que c'était important de venir
rencontrer dialoguer échanger pour voir
comment plusieurs modèles peuvent
coexister et voir comment demain la
région elle peut être plus en soutien
puissant impulsion aussi d'un
accompagnement à la fois financiers mais
aussi à l'accompagnement montage des
projets qui peuvent exister ici le
candidat entend donc s'il est élu
encourager ce genre d'initiatives mais
note que de grandes disparités existent
dans la région
il faut pas oublier que dans cette
région est aussi beaucoup d'inégalités
beaucoup de difficultés et que notre
priorité
demain à la région ile de france c'est
évidemment favorisé et libérer tout le
potentiel incroyable de cette région
mais aussi enfin résoudre les
innombrables inégalités qui se sont
creusés pendant la crise mais qui existe
est malheureusement bien avant
après avoir visité la ferme des clos le
candidat et la députée se sont rendus
dans d'autres exploitations d'autres
candidats se sont déclarés pour ces
régionales en ile-de-france clémentine
autain pour la france insoumis jordan
ben bella avec le rassemblement national
audrey pulvar pour le parti socialiste
et julien bayou avec europe ecologie les
verts a toujours pas d'annoncé
officielle en revanche pour valérie
pécresse la présidente sortante de la
région ile de france qui devrait bien
être en lice pour ce scrutin des
régionales prévues les 13 et 20 juin
prochains et direction vélizy à présent
pour revenir sur la grande campagne la
grande collecte nationale des restos du
coeur au programme le week-end dernier
les 5 6 et 7 mars et dans les yvelines
700 bénévoles répartis sur 55 points de
collecte on écoute des donateurs au
supermarché auchan de vélizy c'était au
micro d'astrid berger
c'est une cause qui nous touche et
c'est un peu la moindre des choses ouais
je suis une fidèle des restos du coeur
comme le téléthon aussi et ça peut nous
arriver à tous
moi j'ai la chance avec la crise
sanitaire j'ai gardé mon boulot de la
génération de coluche donc ça nous sort
de normal d'être élu et d'année un peu
pour les autres qui sont dans le besoin
à chaque fois qu'ils sont des collègues
je donne mais là c'est vrai que j'ai
donné un peu plus parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens avec la
pandémie quand vraiment besoin il ya des
donateurs plus généreux et en nombre ce
qui a ravi bien entendu les bénévoles
des restos du coeur écouter cette année
on est on est vraiment aidé par les dons
en nature comme la et puis les dons
financiers
ouais ouais les donateurs sont vraiment
généreux par rapport à l'année dernière
on avait commencé la collecte une
semaine avant le confinement et là c'est
très très positif on revient sur des
chiffres de 2010 9 l an passé en france
7400 tonnes de denrées ont été récoltés
dans toute la france avec les restos du
coeur l'année 2021 fera t elle mieux
réponse d'ici quelques jours sur le site
internet des restos du coeur
ce week-end c'était aussi la séance du
conseil municipal des jeunes de
voisins-le-bretonneux les élus se sont
réunis pour la première fois tous
ensemble depuis leur élection en
novembre 2020 eléonore sinoquet et
astrid bergère à voisins le bretonneux
le conseil municipal des jeunes sept
enfants réunis en présentiel samedi
dernier après avoir été élu en novembre
crise sanitaire oblige ce premier
conseil a eu lieu au centre sportif les
pyramides et déjà pas mal d'idées ont
été évoquées par les 25 enfants pour
améliorer leur commune on a vu qu'il y
avait plein de proches beaucoup de
sportifs plein dans vie de projet
sportif un petit peu dans tous les
styles sont des jeunes qui présentent
une candidature qui ont qui ont un
projet qui ont des idées pour améliorer
aussi leurs conditions peut-être deux
jeunes dans la ville comme pour les
grands les jeunes se sont fait élire par
leurs pairs profession de foi campagne
électorale dans les collèges et écoles
primaires puis vote une élection en
bonne et due forme qui doit permettre
aux adultes d'avoir une autre vision de
la commune
c'est une force parce que ils voient pas
la ville de la même façon que nous c'est
un lien important parce que nous on a
besoin d'avoir ce lien avec les avec les
plus jeunes
les consulter sur certains domaines
aussi et les jeunes ont plein d'idées
sur lesquels les grands pour elle est
consultée principalement sur
l'environnement mais aussi sur
l'embellissement de la ville ou encore
le tri sélectif mettre des poubelles
pour extrêmement des chiens dans les
villes et toutes sortes toute autre
sorte de poubelle parce qu'il ya tout
les touts les déjà sont mis dans une
salle poubelles à voisins donc si donc
après c'est à eux de faire le tri et
c'est un peu plus compliqué lille ou
comme ces 24 camarades est donc élu pour
deux ans à n'en pas douter au vu de leur
grand nombre d'idées les jeunes comptent
bien travaillé pour améliorer leur
commune n'a depuis 2008 des ateliers
nommé lire et choisir sont organisées
par les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
ils permettent à des collégiens de
sélectionner un livre coup de coeur et
d'en rencontrer l'écrivain cette année
quatorze classes de 5e ont été changées
avec l'auteur caroline perret c'était le
cas notamment au collège paul eluard à
guyancourt
patrick jacques de dixmude et bixente
mayence insisté ban je pourrais dormir
tellement quelques heures par jour en
montée est il des relais colis vers un
moment de partage entre extraits de
lecture question et échangent des
collégiens ont eu l'occasion de
rencontrer colline pirée au triste de ma
fuite chez moi racontant l'histoire
d'anouk une collégienne de 14 ans un
roman qu'ils avaient eux mêmes choisis
dans le cadre des ateliers lire et
choisir s'était bien rencontrer le
christ du livre qu'on a préféré entre
happy end et mafieux chez moi et c'était
bien de lui poser des questions
on lui a fait des dessins vous des
cartes pour dire si on avait aimé les
passages du livre de son livre qu'on
avait bien aimé lire et choisir a été
mis en place depuis 2008 par les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
plusieurs oeuvres coup de coeur sont
sélectionnés par les bibliothécaires
avant que les élèves ne les découvre
haineux
départage cette année c'est le roman
happy end de hann loyers qui partagent l
affiche avec ma fuite chez moi
l'objectif c'est de réunir 14 classes du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
des classes de 5e afin de les proposer
des lectures ou qu'ils puissent les lire
et les choisir pour aboutir à la
rencontre d'auteurs
donc ce qui se passe notamment
aujourd'hui et toujours neuf c'est
toujours différent c'est toujours riche
de pouvoir échanger avec eux de pouvoir
savoir aussi comment ils ont reçu le
livre qu'est ce qu'ils ont qu'est ce
qu'ils en retiennent que ce qu'ils ont
aimé pas aimer qu'est-ce qui les a
touchés
qu'est ce qu'il est et questionne
plusieurs ateliers ont été organisés
avant la rencontre pour réaliser des
dessins choisir des extraits et préparer
les changes avec l'autriche de quoi
permettre aux élèves de maintenir un
lien avec la lecture
il s'agissait de collines thierry nom de
caroline pierre et comme je vous
l'annonçais dans le lancement de ce
reportage à bois d'arcy la ville a
maintenu le week-end dernier son salon
art si féminin pour soutenir le commerce
local et les artisans
il s'est déroulé les 6 et 7 mars dernier
le salon a eu lieu exceptionnellement en
extérieur au domaine de la tramblais
l'objectif darcis féminin faire
découvrir une sélection de talents
féminins locaux magnétiseur créatrice de
bijoux de biscuits ou encore de bougies
une vingtaine de commerçants au total a
participé au salon et en plus bonne
nouvelle le soleil et les visiteurs
étaient au rendez vous propos recueillis
par mélanie poquet eléonore sinoquet
avec le co vite ça fait du bien de voir
du monde et en plus il fait beau donc
c'est l'idéal
chez le marché de bois d'arcy déjà
tous les quinze jours et donc on m'a
proposé naturellement de venir ici donc
j'ai répondu favorablement entrepreneuse
féminine il faut commencer cause des
marques de qu'on dise qu'on est là on
est présente sur le marché il n'y a pas
que les hommes
avant de vous laisser une émission à ne
pas manquer ce soir sur les ondes de
radio sensations fréquence 98.4 dans les
yvelines à partir de 21h et nouveau
numéro de sensations en scène autour
d'hugo casadamont et de son invité
magloire interview avec des artistes
session live musical vieux et surprises
le tout enregistré sur la scène du
théâtre de fontenay-le-fleury je vous
propose d'écouter cet extrait avec un
live du groupe de rock
winder 6
[Musique]
je
sensation en scène ce soir à 21h sur les
ondes de radio sensations fréquence 98.4
dans les yvelines et en des abbés plus à
paris et dans le reste de l'île de
france voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]